more and more passengers taking a ride  underground thanks to the so-called  vegas loop today we got a tour of the  newest stop at resorts world connecting  the tunnels already running under the  convention center casino execs believe  this will really set them apart from the  rest until the next expansion  being the new guy on this side of the  strip  we're still it's going to take a little  time for business to shift this way so  it'll give us a big advantage and make  it easier like i said to get people down  here to our side of the street  the county has already approved plans to  grow through more of the strip and make  stops at unlv and allegiant stadium  earlier this month the las vegas city  council gave the boring company to go  ahead to connect to stop at the strat to  fremont street